nous sommes tous les Palestiniens nous
sommes tous les Palestiniens nous sommes
tous les plusieurs milliers de personnes
étaient présentes à Paris pour une
nouvelle manifestation pour soutenir la
Palestine alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'au départ elle était interdite
et finalement en pleine manifestation
vers 18h45 le tribunal administratif
saisi par les organisateurs a levé
l'interdiction qui avait été mise en
place par les autorités alors que les
policiers étaient en train d'évacuer
cette place de la République ils ont
finalement reculé dès lors que c'est
interdiction a été levé et finalement
cette manifestation a pu avoir
lieu